buenas tardes a todos
y creo que a césar lo ha dicho a parte
de la llegó historia del arte soy
consultor de turismo y a los consultores
sabéis que nos encanta hacer encuestas
estudios y test entonces voy a hacer un
pequeño estudio rapidito por favor
levantan la mano los que os hayáis ido
de viaje hace poquito en el puente en
verano
todos
aquí hay un oído este verano ahora
levantar la mano por favor los que
pensáis seguir yendo de viaje haciendo
turismo
todos también no
y hay alguno por favor que nunca se ha
ido de viaje o alguna alguien no se ha
ido nunca allí hay un intento pero no le
da vergüenza pues bueno como veis el
turismo es una manifestación global
todos somos turistas en el momento ahora
quiero que penséis escoger uno de
vuestros últimos viajes vale y pensad lo
que hicisteis en ese viaje vale
seguramente si fue a la montaña respirar
estéis hondo disfrutas de las vistas sin
fuisteis a un destino rural seguramente
disfrutarán de una casa rural probaste
gastronomía o quizás os habéis ido una
bodega a probar un poquito de enoturismo
os vistas a la playa a relajarnos pero
siempre con una actitud de conocer
cuando viajamos queremos vivir una
experiencia conocer una cultura conocer
a gente diferente o crecer en el ámbito
personal estamos de acuerdo con eso no
yo creo vale ahora debe dar la vuelta
cuando os digo la palabra turista y la
circunscribe a la ciudad de valencia oa
la ciudad de barcelona seis sinceros que
connotaciones os vienen que os sale en
la cabeza o salen connotaciones un
poquito negativa es verdad pues muy mal
porque digo esto porque sinceramente
creo que es un poquito injusto nos
parece es decir cuando nosotros somos
los que viajamos todo es genial
somos un viajero en un turista comenta
ante la distinción viajo conozco me lo
llevo lo retengo luego lo cuento lo que
he hecho comparte experiencias claro
verá cuando me visita a la gente me
parece un poquito mal verdad compartir
mi espacio pues bueno sí que es un
poquito injusto
esto pero os diría que no es no es culpa
vuestra esto está totalmente relacionado
con
pues bueno bien es es intrínseco al
turismo está esta doble moral que
tenemos de hecho fijaros cuando la gente
me pregunta a qué me dedico yo yo
siempre les digo turismo y me dicen yo
defino defendemos lo que haces como lo
ves que es el turismo y yo siempre les
digo les digo me dedico a esto y trabajo
con esto y la gente me dice en juan que
materialista con dinero y digo si el
turismo es una fuente de riqueza pero yo
siempre les digo del turismo lo veo como
una moneda como una moneda que tiene dos
caras una cara y una cruz una cara y una
cara b vale entonces además la línea que
separa una cara de otra que la moneda la
tenemos al aire y caiga de un lado de
otro es prácticamente cosa del azar es
una línea muy estrecha por eso os voy a
contar os voy a hablar de estas dos
caras
voy a empezar por la cara amable por lo
que sería la parte de la moneda de la
cara el turismo sabemos todos que es un
elemento de desarrollo brutal incluso al
lado de meter lo identifica como un
sector económico para el desarrollo de
comunidades más desfavorecidas
tenemos un ejemplo muy claro españa es
un país que sale de la posguerra
bastante dañado a nivel económico paro
etcétera recesión y sabéis que españa en
los años 60 apuesta por un desarrollo
basado en el turismo y despega se pone
al nivel de europa somos la playa europa
se genera un volumen tremendo de empleo
etcétera etcétera fijaros que españa el
turismo supone el 14% del pib lo que es
una verdadera brutalidad 2,5 millones de
empleos genera el turismo directamente
más los que genera indirectamente y
además fijaros que entre 2016 2006 y
2018 prácticamente todos los sectores
todos los empleos de los sectores
económicos españoles de crecieron en el
turismo subió un 13% es decir somos un
país en el turismo no se ha vuelto a
salvar nos salvo en la posguerra y no se
ha salvado ahora
ejemplo más cercano la ciudad de
valencia la ciudad de valencia en los
años 90 no la encontrábamos en los
circuitos turísticos nacionales ni en
los circuitos internacionales éramos una
cia con una feria que venían
comerciantes etcétera pero no era una
ciudad no era un ícono turístico de
españa de repente la ciudad toma
conciencia y se apuesta por introducir
esta actividad turística diferentes
hitos van con la canda valencia en el
mapa la ciudad de las ciencias la copa
américa la restauración del carmen
algunos con mayor o con menor acierto
pero consiguen que valencia se convierta
en lo que es hoy una ciudad con mucho
turismo datos muy sencillito fijaros que
en el año 2000 valencia tenía apenas 99
hoteles que generaban 1,5 millones de
pernoctaciones decir gente que duró
menos 3 hoteles y eso es usted les
generaban mil 300 empleos directos nos
vamos al año pasado
2017 y tenemos casi 150 hoteles 4
millones de pernoctaciones frente a 1,5
comerciantes y todo ello con 2.200
personas se empleasen
pero que queda claro verdad el impacto
que tiene directamente a nivel económico
de empleo de bienestar social el turismo
en un territorio inglés se desarrolla
pero
qué pasa con la cruz qué pasa con la
cara ve como os decía el turismo ese
sector muy complejo y su complejidad y
su cara b se ocupa sobre estar presente
en su propia gestión fijaros que es un
sector que es propicio al desarrollismo
a la especulación porque es un sector
muy rentable a todos los actores que
están implicados en el administración
empresarios sociedad cuando lo ven
quieren apostar por él a botepronto
porque va a aportar una serie de
beneficios este sector
y además fijaros que es un sector entre
comillas globalizado todos los países
desarrollados viajan es decir todo el
que vivimos en un país medianamente
desarrollado viajamos todo el mundo está
viajando el mundo testigo de esto es que
le mete el año pasado registró 1300
millones de llegadas internacionales en
el mundo o sea increíble fijaros que
además el 20% de estas llegadas se
produce en europa europa seguimos siendo
el gran destino turístico del mundo
un ejemplo más cercano españa qué pasa
en españa españa está sometida ahora
mismo a una increíble presión turística
es parte de esa cara de españa en el año
2008 registra nuestro por así decirlo
nuestra estándar normal de nivel
turístico entre cuarenta y largos y
cincuenta y pocos millones de llegadas
de turistas internacionales y el año
pasado que todo lo habéis visto en los
medios hicimos 80,4 récord maravilloso
nos damos golpes en el pecho pero
fijaros que son 30 millones de turistas
más en apenas 10 años casi lo que hace
un destino como gran bretaña en ese
escaso lapso de tiempo nosotros contamos
con ese sobre turismo esa es la cara vez
del turismo que ocurre que si no
conseguimos planificar eso podemos tener
problemas problemas como si yo os digo
centre y fijación o suena a muchos de
vosotros si os digo turismo fobia yo
creo que suena también fijaros que como
buen consultor que soy fijaros turismo
fobia pintadas lo vivimos el verano
pasado pasado nada por favor fijaros que
a mí me gusta definirlo el impacto
negativo que tiene un tris monterreal me
gusta definirlo con cinco afirmaciones
vale una de ellas creciente dependencia
del turismo por la comunidad receptora
es decir cuando turismo se desarrollan
demasiado en un lugar se abandona otros
sectores a lo mejor y se desarrolló sólo
este segunda consecuencia división
social en que entre que se benefician o
caso de barcelona el turismo se
concentra en el centro y lo que son las
afueras de barcelona se quejan dicen
jolín vale tener mucho turismo pero se
lo llevan siempre los mismos 30
especulación del suelo no hace falta que
se explique nada
cuarto inflación de los precios también
nosotras las consecuencias que tiene a
veces el desarrollo excesivo turístico o
expropiación territorial de zonas
autóctonas es decir para ese desarrollo
turístico vinculado al terciario pues es
propia en algunas zonas que estaban
dedicadas a otras cosas
a alguien no le suena esto vi gente que
levanta la mano otra vez o suena vigente
verdad os suena actual sabéis quién
determinó estos factores el profesor
emmanuel de kant lo conocéis antropólogo
belga que escribió especulación móvil ya
no me falta un factor perdona lo
escribió el profesor de canto un
antropólogo belga que escribió un libro
que yo recomiendo que se llama turismo
pase aporte para el desarrollo se
pregunta y lo escribe en el año 1979 es
decir lo que os acabo de decir os sonaba
totalmente vigente en valencia en parte
lo estamos viendo aparecerá una estacada
con lo está viviendo venecia lo está
viviendo pues el profesor de canto en el
año 1969 lo clava además diciendo lo
sobre comunidades indígenas fijaros
comunidades indígenas frente a urbes del
siglo 21 o sea que esto da que pensar ya
qué pensarías alguna pregunta
cuarenta y pico años después estamos
igual no tenéis que estamos igual con
los mismos problemas yo diría que
estamos peor y porque digo que estamos
peor y me siento tan pesimista en este
punto de la charla porque en el año 79
no teníamos toda la información que
tenemos el turismo es un sector nuevo
que queremos desarrollar en demasía no
existe ni la carrera ni los estudios de
turismo no tenemos las fuentes de
información y la tecnología que tenemos
hoy en día y bueno nos podíamos permitir
entre comillas planificar mal pero
llegar hoy en día a los límites que
llegamos conocéis el efecto venecia no
suena está bautizado así cuando un
destino se desarrolla tanto un turismo
que se despuebla que es un teatro es una
figuración el efecto barcelona también
está muy presente en la mente de los
españoles y tenemos miedo de que nos
pasen nuestras vidas como puede ser el
caso de valencia pues bueno todos esos
problemas tienen una solución
aparentemente sencilla pero muy
complicada que cuáles
y una línea decir hasta cuando si te
querés llamar establecer la capacidad de
carga el equilibrio el umbral de
rentabilidad y esto es una cosa que no
es nueva en cualquier curso de primero
de turismo se estudia tenemos que ser
valientes y sobre todo dibujar esta
línea cuando estamos en el éxito no
tiene ningún sentido que esta línea de
dibujemos cuando estamos cuesta abajo y
sin frenos vale después de ponerme tan
negativo ahora vamos a un poquito de
positividad que recetas hay para
conseguir hacer esto yo me he traído
tres dedos las voy a pasar un poquito
por encima y una me voy a me voy a
extender un poquito pero luego habrá una
ponente que se los podrá extender más
fijaros liderazgo compartido para mí la
clave como consultor y profesional que
me recorro españa trabajando lo digo por
favor la parte pública que tiene mucha
implicación y el desarrollo turístico y
la parte privada se tienen que poner de
acuerdo en ser valientes en marcar esos
límites
en equilibrar en hacer un balance que
esto sea rentable no podemos seguir
batiendo récords día a día a costa de
números tenemos que ver la rentabilidad
a todos los niveles social
medioambiental cultural y económica
y segundo punto crucial ejecutar
ejecución estratégica tenemos miles de
planes que dicen todo esto pero nunca se
llevan a término porque no somos capaces
de hacer que las cosas sucedan ejecución
y ejecución ejecución más que
planificación ejecución y el tercero es
la inteligencia la gobernanza hoy en día
tenemos un nuevo paradigma en los
destinos turísticos que son los destinos
turísticos inteligentes tenemos una
ingente cantidad de tecnología entiendo
con suena el big data puesta a
disposición de los gestores de turismo
para que seamos capaces de leer con
anticipación lo que puede pasar en un
destino cuando pueden venir cuando no
pueden venir lo que se van a gastar lo
que quieren ver lo que no quieren ver en
dónde se encuentran la procedencia de la
gente por el dinero que sacan por el
dinero que saca de un cajero las plazas
de aparcamiento libres por vídeo mapping
es decir podemos hacer una gran cantidad
de cosas que debemos aprender a tomar
decisiones inteligentes eso es la
gestión del conocimiento conseguir datos
carlos y tomar decisiones inteligentes
sólo así seremos capaces de tirar la
moneda al aire y que caiga de cara como
nosotros queremos muchas gracias a todos
y espero que os haya gustado